عندما طلبت سيرا ميري ريغيف الأبوة
فيما يتعلق بفريق التفتيش الداخلي الذي أنشأته راماتيل
للتحقق من جنح الجيش يوم السبت شفاراتشا ريجيف
المطالبة إذا كان الجيش يحقق نريد أيضا عشرة
ريجيف هل تم تشكيل لجنة تحقيق في الجيش بسبب التقصير؟
رد راماتال السابع من أكتوبر الآن نحن مشغولون
في القتال، تصر الوزيرة ريجيف على أنك لم ترد علي
السؤال يتدخل الوزير دودي س.س أريد أن أفهم
بدلاً من القتال، ما عليك فعله هو العبث
حاول في التحقيق أن يوضح أن هذا كان فريقًا
أنه يدرس فقط إخفاقات الجيش التي قد يكون لها تأثير
إن استمرار القتال ليس بديلاً عن المراجعة الوطنية
الفرق بين التحقيق والتحقيق مهم جدا
وجاء التحقيق للتحقق من اسمه الذي جاء التحقيق للتحقق منه
كيف نفعل ذلك في المرة القادمة، من الأفضل ألا نفعل ذلك
لقد فهم أن البحث عن الجنة هو ما فعله رئيس الأركان
أنه كان هناك خلل كبير جدًا في 7 أكتوبر
في القيادة والسيطرة على نقل القوات في المخابرات
وهذا الشيء الذي يريد إصلاحه من واجبه إصلاحه
لقد أخبرك الوزير ييب شو شابتون الرجل ذات مرة
مرة أخرى خمس مرات ما الذي تنتقده؟
عليه قاله وزير القوات العسكرية ما فهمت ما أنت
قفز رئيس الأركان وشرح بالضبط ما كان يتحدث عنه الوزير
سموتريتز، معدتي ممتلئة للجيش وأنا صامت
وينتظر انتهاء الحرب، رع شيش بيطون على الجيش
معدتك ممتلئة ويجب على المستوى السياسي أن يوافق على تريتز
ويستمر هدار جمداني من الآن فصاعدا فهو المطلوب
إن إملاء سياسة على السلحفاة لإزالة فم المذنب هو أمر نعم إلى حد ما
فقط السلحفاة كانت هنا في العام الماضي، وليس أنت، الحكومة
كنت هنا كسلام، لا تخجل من ذلك الشبيتون
لا إجابة شهم لم أكن أعرف هذا الفريق
لكنني أدعم الهرمل، وأنت تجلس هنا في المنتصف
حرب ضد العسكريين الذين يشنون حربًا وهذا ما
أنك مشغول به الوزراء الذين شاركوا في المدرسة الدينية
يقولون أن المدرسة الدينية ربما تكون الأكثر إشكالية
والتي كانت من بداية الميل الذي عاشه فلو ليفكروا فيه
أن هذا الشيء لا يمكنه اتخاذ قرارات بشأني
الحرب وخلاصة القول كما قال أحد الوزراء
ليس لدي أدنى شك في أن كل شيء كان مخططاً له يا نجل رئيس الوزراء
إلى الوزير، بما أن نتنياهو لم يقل م لحوالي
الفترة التي هاجموا فيها رفع الوزير بن غابي
يقول مرة أخرى المفهوم الذي تحضره للأشخاص الذين
تم قطع الرباط الافتراضي ويقول الوزير باغانتز إننا افتقدناه
شفناكم كيف الوضع الأمني ​​في البلاد
تتحسن في عامك، هارمل يتحدث إليك ويفعل
بحث سخيف حول ما هو مطلوب من وجهة نظر عسكرية
لخدمة الحرب، هذه استنتاجات ضرورية في الوقت الراهن
يحاول هرمات مرة أخرى درء الانتقادات الباردة هنا
شيء يجب أن يتعلمه الجيش من الغد
نريد حدثًا آخر في قطاع آخر
لا أفهم ما هو الخطأ في التسلسل القيادي
التحقيق مع الاستنتاجات الوطنية هو مجرد تحقيق
للجيش، يمكن أن يكون مرهقا للغاية
لقد بدأت حكومة الجيش الإسرائيلي بالفعل بالتحقيق ولا تنتظر
لليوم التالي لأنه يعلم أنه إذا كان الجيش يستطيع ذلك
للتحقيق في الحرب فيمكنه أيضًا البدء في التحقيق
في الحرب ومن الواضح أنه سيكون أحد الأشخاص هنا
أنهم هم المسؤولون والمسؤولون عن هذا السؤال برمته
ومن المناسب له أن يهاجموا رئيس الأركان وذاك
أنه يجرؤ على بدء التحقيق في منتصف الحرب وأنا
تحاول المشي على البيض وعدم الزيارة، لكنها ليست كذلك
ومن الممكن أن يجري الجيش تحقيقات أيضاً
نريد أن نفعل كيريم في دار جام ديني شير
الأمن جالانت ميري أنا لا أعمل لديك دعني
ليتحدث رئيس الأركان يريد أن يطول أمد الحرب في الشمال
معالي الوزير سموتريتز، من المستحيل أن يقوم الجيش بإجراء تحقيقات
وبعد انهيار مفهوم العشرين عامًا، قام بإزالة قواته
وتم إسقاط جندي من الجيش لإجراء هذه التحقيقات
التحقيقات لاستخلاص الدروس سارة ريجيف لدينا
البطن ممتلئة بالجيش ونحن نمنع السير تروبر
لدينا أيضًا معدة ممتلئة ونتراجع أيضًا
يناشدك جليند ألا تنضم إلى الجيش في هذه المرحلة في نتانيا
ربما شعر بالفعل بالارتياح لأن المحادثة ستنتهي منذ فترة طويلة
القضية الأصلية ليست أقل مشحونة سياسيا
وفي اليوم الذي بعد أن قدرنا وأعلنا أننا بحاجة إلى التوقف، سنكمل
وقت
آخر